hey guys welcome back to the just pearly
things channel it's jess and pearl and
today we are going to be reacting to um
patrice o'neill we have heard so much i
don't know
and so many people have been like react
to patrice o'neill we're like who is
this i didn't i didn't even know who
this was i thought it was a woman before
we get into that make sure you like
comment and subscribe to the channel oh
memberships i'm sorry what are you doing
sorry what are you doing memberships we
got a new vlog drop in it's probably
already out but you can only see it if
you are an exclusive member so sign up
for memberships we have more perks
coming out our discord link is working
now so go ahead and sign up for it
you're going to get so much stuff and
you'll be able to see just a little bit
more of
us and ish and have more fun with us
without further ado let's get started
i hope he's funny i i hope so too
[Applause]
you
look at this girl's face like the stone
indian which that's your girl bro
oh
i like that i like that you feel that
you know what he said he said look at
her and look at me that was a compliment
to you or to her
oh
i thought it was to you and i thought
you was kind of good looking
so that head was kind of like
would you take that as a compliment if a
dude was like look at her not look at me
like would you take that out of the car
i would think he's saying that like i'm
out of his league no you wouldn't
could go either way it could go either
way i could go with you because i feel
like if a woman says that to a man he's
like yeah she's good looking and
wouldn't take offense to it
but she meant you so but we all thought
you meant that so basically he was
saying that she's too pretty
it's like a beta move though ah what i'm
saying because it's like if he's putting
her on a pedestal
so that's like that's like a beta
mindset so it like makes you lose
attraction because you're like if he's
not sure of himself how am i supposed to
be sure of you
they don't know what they're doing but
red pill lens
run to live wow
see my i i don't have i don't have the
right ones yet
they got that misconstrued because they
couldn't believe somebody could be that
much of a lying ass
liar
see what happens when you lined up it's
just whatever is she just a friend of
yours
so how long you been trying to how long
you've been trying
how long you've been trying to have sex
with her and friendship your way into it
it ain't gonna happen she's gonna use
you
until you're finished she's gonna tell
you all kind of her problems she's going
to have you go out to dinner with her
hair annie up man have her annie up man
give it up how long you been knowing him
uh uh not having a good time how long
you been knowing this guy
because i don't like her i don't even
know i don't like her already she's just
sitting there
hey
she's not fun
and you've been trying to make this
unfun [ __ ]
one day lay down and give you some booty
by what how how how
hey
i mean he ain't lying why
why do women do that like well we'll
keep a dude around and like the
friendship zone knowing that we will
never
ever do anything with him but we'll keep
that have you ever done that no
no because i haven't cuz
who was on the phone during the 20 no no
no no no no no
no no no that's different no no no
that's like truly like a friend like
truly truly he asked you on a date it's
not gonna happen i promise you it's not
gonna happen but that the same way it's
not gonna happen to them
but still why do you do that jess
chill out but no i'm saying like
why because
you know he's trying to smash i no i
wouldn't let him it's the same thing
but i wouldn't like i wouldn't just use
them like that's what i'm talking about
why do females like but you don't
understand see this is like that's a
girl's point of view i'm not using him
but if you're taking his time and
attention but i'm not do i'm saying i'm
not doing it talking to him on the phone
hanging out with him that's what friends
do
do men friends talk on the phone jess i
don't talk on to the phone with him
every day okay okay do men do men just
talk on the phone don't they
do men not talk on the phone correct me
if i'm wrong it's okay it's like this is
just you're looking at it from a female
point of view from a man's point of view
it's like they have nothing in common
with us the only reason they like to
hang dealing with us is because we're
pretty and they want to have sex then
i'm not having no more guy friends this
is like yeah no that's that's a weird
realization but i've i've had a guy
where he's been interested but like from
my point of view like he knows it's
never gonna happen i've been very clear
so if he wants to keep being friends
like that's not my fault yeah but like
i've had situations like that but that
it's like at the same time think of it
from a guy's point of view right he lets
her know what it is that he's not going
to be seen in public with her right
that that this is a casual thing and she
keeps doing it is it still right no yeah
yeah it's like the that's the opposite
it's us taking their time attention and
resources gotcha you learn something new
every day folks
uh so we're going to start with i really
missed him he's been around for a minute
no i think he passed away
okay
i'm really hate to see it go man i
really was happy watching chinese people
walking around
uh not trying to cough you know you know
but i just love watching chinese people
get the pressure applied looking at them
like waiting for them to cough you know
you when you was working with him he was
just looking around
if he cough
if this chinese do coughs it was just
fantastic because every other disease
they blame on black people i can't get
enough of it
i'm watching uh tv monkey parks and
it was doing some magical disease white
people breaking out with this
and uh
and so i'm looking and they're doing the
report and they show a composite sketch
of some rat
uh
from africa which
which means he's black and they drew it
first of all i'm like what's this how do
you know the difference between some
some uh black rat and some rat from the
bronx
that's
the puerto rican hat so they they might
as well
drew a hat backwards and so
so this is the monkey park culprit watch
out for the watch out for the dirty
black rat and then
uh uh it attacked it attacked uh
now white people don't really have an
animal representative of themselves
but if he was to think of a few
one would be a bald eagle and the other
would be a prairie dog and that's what
it attacked so it's almost just like a
newscast be on the lookout for something
right uh
he
he uh bit uh some poor defenseless uh
prairie dog just watching the game and
stole his wallet and bit him in the
shoal and gave him what would you say
would be an animal for white people an
orangutan and a ragged
i can't tell you why
carry on
wait wait what about black people first
thing that popped in my head was a pit
bull an orangutan stole his wallet you
got him in the shoulder and gave him
yeah
i'm watching this bug show with the
locusts man
you know black locust from africa black
watch out for black
locusts africanized that's what they
call africanized big black locusts
watch out because they
they eat up all the crops and they don't
tip and
watch out
watch out for the locusts
and y'all know about the monkey
monkey got charged up with all kind of
the monkey a's ebola
i'm not even really scared of a's
anymore
i mean cause how can you with magic you
see magic johnson he looks fantastic
i can't be afraid he looks wonderful
he's had aids for 15 years
what kind of age he got the good guy i
want
he's been he's been opening movie
theaters
and starbucks for the last 15 years i
want that kind of age give me that
make me a better entrepreneur i need
that
patrice you got aids good i want to open
a trucking company i've thought about
that before i'm like
doesn't it doesn't magic
have a
good question yeah
no
no
okay whatever you're gonna ask okay
ask you go ahead smash your pass oh pass
but okay magic johnson he's okay
hear me out hear me out he's taking care
of your bills the rest of your life he's
giving you giving you kids right i think
how are you gonna give me kids he got
aids
i think you can like i think he can
still i think there's like drugs it's
like i don't i don't know i've never
i've never had aids so i don't know i
wouldn't risk it but i i've heard it's
like like that other sexual thing that
people get but they take drugs and then
they can still have sex um
like like i know someone that's dating
someone that like has some std that
doesn't go away but like they take drugs
and they don't get it i i think it's the
same thing you wouldn't risk it nope no
no i wouldn't risk it because what if
the child comes out with it and then
that's my fault
no yeah fair play fair play patrice
he's funny we would have a good time but
no people friend zone yeah
patrice you got it's good i want to open
a trucking company because
this crowd is tough man
you know chinese people didn't laugh out
there
but the black people in the chinese
people wrote they all laughing at the
thing right but they
that's young girls for you boy the young
girls do that y'all the only thing good
about young girls y'all young girls you
know you're young you know look
delicious
you know
other than that
that's so true
and they're getting bigger too man these
young brothers man damn you see them
i think the stuff they put in the
chicken and all that stuff all that
that that you know what i mean
they walking around big i saw this woman
walking down the street i was like damn
you fine how old are you she was like
four
[Music]
he could not he did not make a joke like
that today oh yeah but i i don't i think
this is like i don't know when he passed
away because this it looks old but what
he's talking about sounds recent because
he was talking about kovid and he's
talking about monkey pox and so that's
something that
just came about trace o'neill i think
he's just been in comedy for a while his
death oh he died at 41
in one year
holy
2011. 2011 he died yeah since
1969 to 2011. how is he talking about
let me let me yeah i know it says 2011.
i couldn't tell you talking about
covet and
did you say covert
he was talking about how
they i don't there may have been another
disease that they essentially blamed on
i think it was bad
blamed on uh
the asian community um but monkey pox we
haven't heard nothing about no monkey
pox until
this like year i said you got some nice
titties before
like i can't spell if i had to spell
restaurant
to this day right
to save my mama's life like if if
like if somebody held my mom a hostage
she had a gun to her
shoot your mother in the head i'll be
like i would look at my mother like uh i
love you
you gotta look at me mom she's crying
[Applause]
understand that i
i love you with all my
heart
it's my restaurant
r-e-s-t-a-u-r-a-n-t
it's called onomatopoeia
onomatopoeia that's how i'm spelling it
like the one like word that i i always
knew it's spelling good for you
because
i thought you were going to press the
space bar and say small restaurant so i
was like let me beat her do it because
could you have smelled it it took oh it
took me a minute
i'm horrible i already already thought
of it in my head yeah i was just trying
to spell it as like restaurant and i was
like okay let me how can i spell it no
it's hard spawning's hard we don't even
need to spell we got we got google
autocorrect yeah we don't even my life
would be messed up if we didn't have
auto correct i would be like jesus help
me
stop stalling [ __ ] okay all right all
right
all right
all right all right all right all right
r-e-s-t
oh my god here's where it gets
oh jesus christ
uh
there's an uber
uh
[Applause]
you
all right give me another give me
another word man give me no words one
more word
just give my mother a chance to live
tomorrow yo i wrestle
you're crying
he's like there's a ooh in there
i know brother you never made the
spelling bee did you oh no
i stayed on the basketball court and
that was my area okay i'm gonna tell you
when i was a kid we had these like
sticker charts right and every time you
had 100 on a spelling test you would
like put a sticker on the chart
and
i was so bad at spelling that i was
still on the first chart and i only had
two stickers all year
and like me and my friend emily were the
only ones in the whole class oh
look at spelling i didn't know how to
spell restaurant but like it's probably
not my forte yeah i would i would have
been at the bottom of the totem pole
yeah it's too bad we didn't know each
other we could have yeah i would have
been like hey at least you're not last
place
probably god
banana all right banana banana b-a-n
b-a-n-a-n-a
good job that's okay so i was thinking
about this the other day a lot of songs
not a lot of songs but a big chunk of
songs that we had like growing up gave
us like words to spell
like uh gwen stefani that is banana
b-a-n-in it that's
[Music]
oh yeah just like songs like that i i
have to i could not just feel like
independent just normally i have to like
sing that song to be like spell
independent o n o m a t o p o e i a i
don't like here oh i was like what song
is that
nothing
[Applause]
all right how many guys in here honestly
have used a dental dam before
do you know what a dental dam is
you do no one's ever used one before huh
see
see what i'm saying you see what i'm
saying about the condoms y'all just like
put that condom on but you know the
dental dam is it's a piece of a trash
bag right
ah that's not good about as big as a
napkin that you flip out and you lay it
over a woman's vagina
just in case you know it's it's it's
poison
[Music]
to protect us from imminent danger but
we don't use it because you'll be
insulted
if i'm getting ready to have sex with
you and i'll pull out a piece of a trash
can
and you go uh what is that oh i'm just
gonna lay that over your vagina what
would you do for me i would be of sex i
know i'm not in the streets i feel like
you're fine like i'm not in the streets
i've been tested blah blah blah but if i
was
i did see it if a dude knew that i was
sleeping around why wouldn't you just
use a condom i guess it's extra
protection oh it's like on top of the
condom it's like a condom and a dental
dam yeah i'm guessing they use both the
extra protection
just in case it kills me
i'm sorry what did you say and we see
that face like nothing forget it don't
even pretend i didn't see that i'd
rather die than to
insult my way out of some i'd rather
just get what you got
that is true females do have access to
sex like you're talking about yeah men
have access to relationship females yeah
wow
like one of us proposes
honestly though i think the men we want
have access to relationships in a way
yeah like i think it's like a small
percentage of men have access to
relationships with the other percentage
it's like they'll take what they can get
anyway
and it's almost on the woman yeah i'm
not about to propose to nobody and y'all
know out there
also
stop dming both of us
we talk
we talk
we love you guys though
i love you
i just want to feel special i know
i think they're gonna rub speed for this
how many people get sick of the hindu
obstacle course at the
airport it's just it is
i mean i'm a racist but it's
it's getting
and i don't mind foreigners but don't be
from your cut like
from your country like it's okay to be
originally from there like your parents
and grandpa but you can't be from india
and even that would for my ability
id you go what the [ __ ] i know i'm
american i i got to be more american
than you because i don't go hebrew
yo comedy back in the day is
unmatched to nowadays like
you could say anything you could
literally say anything do anything
on comedy
stages and at performances nowadays it's
so censored that it's like oh if i say
this one thing i might get cancelled or
insensitive it's like man i love old
school comedy yeah
man i know my voice
proves i'm american like i need another
i need an american voice to ask me for
my [ __ ] but you can't get rid of the
double day dudes cause
they're amazing like who else will work
at a 24-hour brooklyn gas station with
no bulletproof vest and no gun
and curse [ __ ] out if they don't have
less than a 50.
you need something smaller please 50
double
[Applause]
you can't get rid of them because they
do jobs nobody else is going to do
that's why you can't really listen what
is this thing where we trying to get
mexicans out this country who else is
going to work
without mexicans and who else is going
to work
who else would drive
a bicycle
on the highway who else a rider
who else would ride away man who else
would ride a bicycle on the highway
against traffic to deliver you
a panini sandwich for lunch
on
time who else
that's true it's like even though people
are like oh all the foreigners are
taking
our jobs in america he's like they're
really not they're taking the jobs that
people don't want to do and
there's a video i saw earlier and that
men essentially do the jobs that women
don't want to do it's like we need we
need men well and we're not having
enough kids in the us so like
a population a like a
a population that's getting smaller is
like a really big threat to civilization
because no one can fill jobs
so it's actually like i think they
should look at immigration like a
competition like trying to get the best
talent that'd be interesting yeah
because you need
like like right now i think there's a
shortage in like a lot of the medical
fields really i start popping how babies
repopulate with who
with the right sutas you get the right
sutes
we could be the superior superior family
i mean
what as many as i need to change the
world no i'm kidding
how many kids you are only two two and a
perfect world too but i would go four at
most i want like eight see you came from
a big family i know i know i just don't
think i have enough time because i'm 25.
like like that's like eight so that's
like ten years come on
i know i'd like have to start you have
to back to back yeah
fine i'll do five
who else is gonna uh
kick in your hotel door to make your bed
besides some little mexican woman who
has an ethic she has to make your bed i
have to i have i have to make hello and
she knocks that she [ __ ] punches the
door
and she scares the [ __ ] out she kicks
the [ __ ] door and the chain is on
hello
hello and you're like miss the chain is
i'm alive the chain's on the door you
don't have ma'am please look
please i must make your bed i must
make your bed i must make your bed
please
these are like nice hotels they're
they're they're making your bed
they don't even like and then pass if
you say no no thank you damn
you pull out a [ __ ] ideas
[Applause]
and she's trying to squeeze in through
the space
through the chain space
like hello
hello
i must make you laugh
[Applause]
i wish i never traveled forever bro
because i could i would like just never
had travel outside this country and then
i could hate america
and be happy you know what i'm saying
but
i traveled
and now it's like i'm now i like america
but i still hate it's weird i hate it
but
it's nowhere better because all i got to
really deal with is racist crackers like
that and that's
that's it's funny because like i don't
black people really don't look at white
people with like you're the oppressor
anymore it's just something we do it's
just like we like not liking white
people and white people like not liking
us it's like it's a game we do is just
because i'm not going nowhere and i'll
kill a [ __ ] he told me to go
like back to africa listen i'm talking
to black people stop that [ __ ]
horseshit that
go back to africa's [ __ ]
first of all africans
don't like black people that's first of
all
they don't like us that's
it sucks but it's true not all there's
some that some that are very like oh
like you need to go back home you need
to come back to africa blah blah blah
but there's some that just downright
don't
like
american black people or african
americans and they just said you're not
really african
you you can't call yourself
african-american because you're not from
there and i can understand that i can
understand them saying you shouldn't
call yourself african-american because
technically they're not originally
technically wonder why they say
african-american like it's kind of weird
when you think about it cause you could
be from like canada
yeah and so you could be from everywhere
and i would say
uh people that like come like nowadays
come from africa and they get become a
citizen in america but that is true and
a lot of there's some people from like
the caribbean like jamaica and the congo
they won't necessarily say oh i'm black
like i knew someone that was like nah
don't call me black i'm jamaican like
don't call me this i'm where i'm from so
it sucks but it's true
and
what the [ __ ] am i gonna do
in africa
besides fighting some war wearing uh
sweatpants and tuxedo shoes
with a [ __ ]
[Applause]
with a [ __ ] machete in my hand with a
pair of [ __ ] tuxedo shoes
and a knife
fighting some goofy ass [ __ ] wall
[ __ ] it
you just gotta be honest with yourself
like okay i believe in god all right but
i don't have a religion
that's cause i'm a coward and that's
that's why i have a religion now i
believe in god but i'm just saying my
thing is i don't mind going to hell
if i'm being a sinner
and i got to go to hell my thing is i'm
afraid of going to hell for being like a
devout
wrong [ __ ] like i i
don't be praying to the wrong god where
i could have been having sexual hookers
or shooting people only time i get
really religious
look at this guy only time i get
really religious
i become a christian when i get on
airplanes that's when i get like you
know
i don't want to play in the crash i'm
helping old ladies with their bags miss
miss no don't
don't know let me get that back home
let me get that put that up there for
you guys
i don't even know her
you ain't gonna let the plane crash are
you
and and i'm full of [ __ ] because when
the woman goes thank you so much for
putting my bag up and i'm like look this
this got nothing to do with you
i'm just trying to keep the plane from
crashing because
because when the plane lands and she's
looking at me like you want to get my
bag i did this
you think he wants to see you
every
day
this face
just look at her face it's just
like a stroke victim just
oh
it's worse when you get roasted it's
better just to laugh and be like
you have to laugh at all because you
just sit there and you're like oh can
you say that oh you said she looked like
a stroke thank you
[Music]
it's just
can you imagine if i'm your man and i
have to be with
like i'm trying to disco dance to make
your life
better
i'm sorry say that again
no no don't even go home that's what i
knew she was gonna say
that's the face she said you have to
make me laugh
she has a master that's what you deal
with
what she has to add yeah
you laugh who's gonna make your
miserableness
that's not my job to pull your misery
from inside your gut
i don't know what happened to you
i can't make the things you're still
dealing with from when you were six
come out and laughter
[Applause]
she and this is why you know she's not
this is women you have movies in your
head
that only star you directed by you
everybody else is laughing and she goes
you have to make me laugh
the fact that laughter's contagious
should help you
damn on the inside okay that's that's
red pill because they always say women
are like solid solid cystic it's always
like i i don't know the word they're
going to happen
but but it's like basically like the way
women communicate it's always about us
we think everything's about us like
naturally so for example if i'm talking
to a man and i say i went to the gym he
might say oh cool what workout did you
do but if i'm talking to a girl she
might say oh i went to the gym too
oh okay okay it's not like we mean it in
that way like we're trying but it's like
how we talk yeah i i've caught myself
like before i knew what it was i would i
would not not purposely do it but now
that i i remember i was talking about a
little bit now that i like know what it
is i'm like
don't don't try to don't
don't try to like resonate like that
just say oh ask a follow-up question
it's funny i tell guys this and they're
like yeah
they're like what
like you guys only want to talk about
you
but it's how we could like it's how we
as women like bond
but like men don't see it like that so
she's doing the same thing like
everyone's laughing she's like we gotta
make me laugh i was like
man
is it not funny everyone else is
laughing
that's you
[Applause]
stop it stop it
you don't know what you're talking about
she does look at that face she knows
don't get mad i'm just saying you need
to stop being so wrapped up but that's
like he's saying you're auditioning
for him to be your man at some point
this guy is a nice guy
he's actually
you know how fast i would get rid of her
as a friend
i would throw something in the garbage
just so i can blame her for stealing it
i'll be like
hey [ __ ] my watch was right here
oh i put it right here [ __ ]
[Applause]
you stole from me huh
cuz i could never talk to her again
don't go too far ahead of me you ever
try to watch the special olympics
and and try not to be uncomfortable
because it's the it's the right thing to
do
[Laughter]
i don't even want to watch the rest
no we gotta we gotta
no
i'm crying because i already know what
he's gonna say
oh i don't even know
oh goodness it starts off have you ever
watched the special olympics and not be
uncomfortable oh
are you sitting there trying to watch
and just
is it bad though we're laughing
brah i mean sometimes
dab right deborah you got one leg i mean
how fast are you supposed to go
i mean daniel
you can't dribble that well in a
wheelchair
shut up pearl shut up
it's impossible to watch you try to you
do because you're a good person
and then marshall said go
[Laughter]
oh my god
and he's inside but what's this guy
doing one day he didn't fall but
he didn't run because the starters
pistol
scared him to death so he's just
standing there
[Laughter]
you gotta shoot at his feet to make a
move or shove him
now you gotta watch out cause the
javelin guy is
running all around with a pointy stick
and he's gonna stay straight ahead you
know he's going to run all over he's
happy
and he can stab you right in your chest
with that sticking through yeah
and if he hit you in your chest you
can't even go out your [ __ ] you can
stab you with a stick
you gotta go oh no
thank you
i hate how much fun black people can
have recently man it's just
i can say anything i goddamn want
racially and why people have to sit
there and take it no
i am evil yes he's like come on man
i i don't even say it because of that i
like i i love i i love a little ratio
yes look man you know
let's be fair i mean
honestly be nicer with the racial game i
mean it i like to talk to uh you know
white people about being honest about uh
obama
you gave it a shot
you did
you gave it a two-year shot like oh yeah
i tried i tried to
we tried to
but you see not it's not it's just
it fell apart it really
it really did and i'm gonna tell you
something you don't know about black
folks
we would be on your side
uh and talking to you we would be on
your side a lot more if you would uh you
know just not ever talk
about how you feel
about anything
racial we'll catch up to you not serious
cause black people are on the edge of
going what the [ __ ] is obama doing
but it's too many white people outwardly
hating him so we can we go if you shut
the [ __ ] you shut up i'll be against
them like stop
i'm running rallies and all that it's
like just wait just wait
just wait y'all gonna have your turn to
speak we promise
did you do you feel like people liked
obama from because i was young
after the fact yeah because you you were
able to vote when you first was in
office no i wasn't dang
i think before they were like
yeah obama after the fact they were like
obama didn't do nothing more than george
bush and i was like how could you say
that but like i've done a lot of
research and i'm like
so yeah i think i think they were for
them
then it just was like
but like he said we couldn't like go
against them because it was like why
it's just his ass his ass i don't get it
like
because like i think bush was a bad
president like i just feel like if you
if their ass their ass
and i'm a diehard conservative is it
it's just like you you're gonna you're
not just gonna get it from everybody
else you don't get it from people and
your family people your friends you just
you're gonna get it from a whole bunch
of other people if you go against a
black person
tell your family i my
my brother
knows a little bit my old brother knows
a little bit about red pill um it's like
i mean i feel like your mom would be so
entertaining to run
she would be she'd be and she if they
ever come out here yeah for graduation
if they're out here you have fairness on
donations we'll fly out yes
do that please do that yes send
donations to fly out and brad pill her
family yeah that's the next issues
issues cameras first and then other
stuff for studios they're about my
family
kind of stuff
i'm telling you i'm this close to
i'm mad at him because i thought i would
have a white slave but i
thought i thought it was vengeance thing
[Applause]
wanna have me a white family oh big old
fat white girl go warm up better get
upstairs susan
warm my bed up feed my baby with your
giant white titties and
i'm gonna go outside and stare your
husband in the face and decide whether
i'm gonna sell them or not
now you know your wife's upstairs
warming up my bed you know that right
phillip
[Applause]
why is everything funnier when you give
someone a name
cut
so i just still be like diane because
it's just like just say if we
just uh didn't name karen's or ken we
just said oh they're just complaining a
lot
it it just has like a resignation with
like a name carries
karen girls are actually named oh yeah
the girls are actually named karen i've
heard people say oh my name's karen i'm
like oh
that's a nice name
why are you lying
it's a nice shot off upset
that's uncomfortable i apologize
i never thought mike tyson
and the reason i'm saying this because
[ __ ] now he's fighting like
farmers they got mike fighting
anybody
just to say mike we want to see you
knock a [ __ ] out again
he was so special as a knockout artist
we hated to see him when he got on the
rape beef that i never believe
especially based on the last interview
we had with greta van susgen and
he goes she goes what do you have to say
to your victims mike he goes well
i wish i had to really rape the [ __ ]
and her mama i wish i had to really rape
the [ __ ] and i'm mama i'm like oh that
is an innocent man that's the i'm
telling you only an innocent man could
be that angry and say some [ __ ] that
[ __ ] up like i i wish i had decided to
been in jail for something instead of
being a [ __ ] and i really didn't so
that's mike's way of like figuring it
all out
i can i can understand that because a
guilty man ain't going to say i wish i
not saying that that is a
good thing at all but when you go to
jail for something you don't do you're
like day i wish i would have did that to
be going to jail for for a reason
dang i that that's true i could i just
how can you do that to make up that's
that something like that about somebody
doing that to you you know it's not true
and her testimony years ago which cut me
off even without the interview but
interview solidified it
her testimony he forced oral sex on me
and i said damn he made you suck his
dick that's terrible
he ate a [ __ ] that's when it was like
case
case dismissed cause
what rapist tries to make you feel
wonderful i
i've been eating [ __ ] in a long time
and i never eat it how the [ __ ] do you
just shut up and shut up
shut up my ninja [ __ ] shut up
i peel away the outer lips and
slide the hood back to expose your
clitoris
for maximum stimulation shut the [ __ ] up
you can't even make a mean face while
you eating [ __ ] you can't you be like
shut up
you better not be enjoying this [ __ ]
[Applause]
has any woman in here be getting a [ __ ]
eating been going hell police
hate my [ __ ] somebody do something
shut up nobody hear your cries
[Applause]
and
another thing that's logic that's just
simple common sense but people won't
even people will dismiss all what not
dismiss it but take her initial word
like oh he me and not here that's the
thing that people will hear what she
said like oh he me from
jump and then won't he listen to the
story and the story like doesn't match
up believe all women yeah regardless of
the facts data statistics and evidence
that's crazy because like that that what
he just said that's common sense like
someone that is going to you isn't going
to please you they're going to do their
thing and they're going to peace out and
you as a woman how you go going
oh my gosh you know what this guy was
here yesterday right that i did a
reaction with and he said in nigeria if
a girl said like invited a guy into her
apartment and then he he grabbed her
after like a date right the police would
just laugh at her because they would say
why was he at your apartment like next
oh wow
but it's kind of like
that's interesting it's kind of true
cause like what what is he doing there
yeah like what well your intention yeah
you weren't gonna sit down and eat tea
and crumpets or something he pounded yam
and a goosey soup like yeah wow that's
interesting
we're like uh
i'm trying to like make it so women just
like understand a little bit of like
just to sympathize it's like we're like
sport fishermen that's what i'm saying
men like to fish
and sport fishing is different from
catching
fish for food you just get it you get it
you catch it
and you you know you you show your
friends
because you want them to know that you
can catch fish
you take a couple of pictures so you can
show people the fish
that you have the ability to catch
and then you release it
back into the water
but a lot of women in here you have
boyfriends or husbands
you were fish that jumped back on the
boat
and just was like flapping looking at me
like
hi
i was wondering if you're going to be
fishing here again next week like
yeah for other fish get off my boat
is that how you treat all the fish you
be like oh god damn
nope i'm sorry sweetie you're the last
fish i ever wanted to be with now you
stuck
stuck with the last fish who was loving
you and fighting hard to be on your boat
then she got comfortable and now instead
of doing this she's like so
we've been together for like
a year now why do you still have a boat
you'd be like
so what's he trying to say i can't catch
fish no more why do you need to get some
fish
because
i lose my ability to catch fish
then you're not gonna find me sexy no
more so you gotta smell fish on me
so that you know i can catch fish
so you can act right
yo
that analogy that's a good analogy good
analogy
that's red pill as [ __ ]
yeah
i like that i'm not you're gonna have to
use that one now
thanks patrice thank you patrice
that's like guys you meet your girl she
was a hoe
like had whole like she big old booty
and this and that you got to let her do
that
don't start trying to frump her up and
get a fat and get a foul
because that's why you like her i don't
want no woman that no other guy is
trying to i don't want a woman
that i can send to the store at two in
the morning
because nobody's gonna try to like i go
go get some bread at three in the
morning hey cut through the alley [ __ ]
cause
cause i talked to the junkies they don't
want it they ain't got they don't like
you
[Applause]
like ladies let's discuss hey look oh
man let's discuss harassment
for a second
let's just see you feel it a little bit
like let's just discuss it
why can't
i harass you
[Applause]
sometimes
sometimes
[Applause]
i can never harass you never and i'm not
talking about
[Applause]
like i'm talking just
[Applause]
at the job
[Applause]
it's unfair bro let's bring back cat
calling
i had it happened to me the other day
look at that look at even if it's a
crackhead i'm like thank you jackhead
one day one day we're gonna be 45 50. no
one's gonna be looking i know we should
appreciate it while it's here we're
gonna be 60 year old woman nobody's
gonna be cat calling us i know you know
i mean speak for yourself don't pray
show me one 60 year old
me
look at it i say bring back cat calling
bring back subtle harassment
subtle like don't don't touch me okay
i'm i'm i'm all for like the the guys
that would just grab your butt at bar
like that's weird i'm not let's keep
that away but i personally never minded
a little cat call it's hard it sounds
not creepy like yeah you like then
they're like you look beautiful miss i'm
like thank you you look beautiful
appreciate it i did my hair today thank
you for noticing crackhead
thank you for knowing joe they even owe
me bob thank you for dylan
tyrone thank you
that i can't harass you at the workplace
like
[Applause]
yeah i am but i feel like women
women can do that to men
and they just come true accept it like
if we
if women saw a man like with a nice
button that it smelled oh nice i like
your butt in those jeans it's just like
oh no so i can do that but if a man did
that to a woman to be like
he said let me fire him and they know
damn well that if he looked good if he
was six four and jack you do not care
yeah if he's sexually hurt yeah yeah
yeah
if it's the if there's the right guy you
don't care they could rope you dirty the
guy i worked with a couple years ago he
could have harassed me any day he could
uh
he wasn't he wasn't interested to be
like that i know shocking but like i was
like i never i was not horrific right
now i was chilling i was doing my job
but he couldn't harass me
is my point yeah
right guys
that's all day
you look at how you looking
and i can't just
a little something that has to do like
you got to be careful just to say hey
you look beautiful today that's how
messed up the game is
i think you should be able to comment on
any part of the body
that you see if you
i'm serious
what's your name
what's your name
genie now jeannie no disrespect but if i
work with you
i should be able to walk in and go oh
genie beautiful uh titty meat you have
there
and
because i see that but
whatever the scientific term is i'm
looking at mr
a 4.9 grade point average what's the
what's the science term for uh to the
titty meat what's the actual
and it's not the cleavage i mean the
cleavage is the space in the middle i'm
talking about the meat
the meat the titty part
and i'm not being fouled just you know
whoa
you know what i'm saying just
what's what's
what's wrong what's wrong about that
if you have it out there
out yeah
and he just they're just complimenting
it like what's
what's wrong because you you know they
look good that's why you have them out
you know your butt looks good that's why
you have it out girls pretend they don't
know oh i just wear this for me shut up
shut up nah there's
there's certain clothes that i wear them
like oh i know my brother don't look
good and then someone said something
like thank you we went out to dinner in
the vlog that's on the ten dollar tier
sign up sign up you can check out our
outfits yeah no we were dressed up
because we were going out yeah and we're
trying to look good yeah
i do look good thank you yeah
thank you now i don't like the word
titty bean
i don't have i wish i wish he just said
tense yeah but who am i to tell you what
to say yeah you see what you see
you say what you say
so
i appreciate the compliment thank you
bring back cat calling bring it back
should we get a t-shirt bring that cat
call me
would you
would you get that shirt if we put it on
bring back cat car i don't think bed
would wear
so i can go through the rest
of the day without pretending
that i don't see
which which you understand what i'm
saying i mean let's work out a deal
don't get me
fired
having women work with men right is like
having a grizzly bear work with salmon
[Applause]
dipped in honey like so
now you dip the salmon in the honey
right grizzly bears and the salmon get
to walk through comfortable with honey
and fish and
good morning grizzly bears
and the grizzly bears is like
hey
he didn't even he didn't even growl like
ah what's up fish
oh my god human resources the grizzly
bear just did grizzly bears
so
[Applause]
so
[Laughter]
that's it like he just said the grizzly
the grizzly bear just did grizzly bear
stuff it's like that's just men yeah man
go do men's stuff but it's like
women don't let men do men's stuff
his analogies are on point
like i can't even go hey good morning
good morning fish good morning
oh i can't touch you like oh look at
that what up mama
just get a little bit of that fish
okay what's your best if you could pick
how the best way like someone could hit
on you what would you want them to say
it all depends on where they're from
let's say that say they're attractive
tall
because it if they're a british guy a
british guy i want a man to come say
like i hello love how you doing today
you're doing all right
i don't know i want i want someone to
talk to me about crumpets crumpets yeah
literally you want to go get some
crumpets
and and i want them to compliment my
hair color i want him to say i have a
thing for gingers you want to get some
crumpets okay you seem hesitant do not
i don't know is that not fire game
i mean for you
you can use it i ain't got ginger here
and i've had krumpus before i had an
aunt uh her family was from over here
i'd be like yeah someone came up to me
i'm like
okay and now if they say hey i
want to show you
around london i'd be like okay cool take
me take me on a trip i'd like to go
someday
take me in
get that honey oh my god
fish and honey man that's my favorite
usually i kill fish and eat them and
stuff but i just wanted to just rub that
rub a little bit of that
god
damn
[Applause]
that's oppressive like you shouldn't
even
and there's cameras everywhere you can't
do
like weird stuff
behind the back like
why would it be disrespectful i said
what's your name
tyrell if i go tight tomorrow we work
together and i go tarot hey do me a
favor let me know when you're getting up
to go to bathroom so i can sniff your
chair
[Applause]
that's disrespectful because it's sexual
but that keeps me from being i'm not
gonna lie i don't know where the line is
that would be weird but if honestly if
he didn't do it
nothing after that it tried to move to
me he just wanted to sniff my truck i'll
be like hey yo patrice i'm about to head
to the bathroom i let one out for you so
you can smell it he's like oh yeah
like
i'm just thinking what if we had
everyone doing that i feel like that
would be disruptive everybody's in the
office hey yo just gonna leave her to
the bathroom start that i know
hey it's lunchtime guys i'm gonna be
gone for about an hour if you just yeah
if you want to if you want to sniff
you want me to just
i think i i've had a little bit of fiber
this afternoon so we won like what you
what you bathed with you smell real cool
you know it's a new scent i try
that's disrespectful because it's sexual
but that keeps me from being
like i think look i think there should
be a holiday
uh for lack of a better word harassment
day but not that sounds whatever but i
mean a day where i
get to
find out like because and this is why it
should be harassment day
because women get to be inappropriate
sex
all the time you get to be inappropriate
and when i say inappropriate i mean
say hello to me
too close him
or some weird massage because you
think we're friends and you morning
little kiss and he's just like oh
oh boy oh boy boy
you think in your head man i wonder if i
could i wonder wrong you know
but harassment day allows you to be able
to ask
oh yeah i say the tuesday
before thanksgiving
[Applause]
and it's and it's a beautiful day
flowers and everything you buy flowers
you're just real cool you walk up you're
respectful you say hey how are you
you know good afternoon to her happy
harassment day
and you just like say listen i was
wondering
all year if you would suck my dick in a
broom clown
[Applause]
and you just be like no thank you i'm
not and you play i'm thank you keep the
flowers i just thought
i made a mistake i thought you was a
whole all year
i was confused i thought you was a hoe
but you're not
huh
that last thing he said about the midday
should we bring it up at this channel
should i i can i can implement it don't
be careful what you wish for i'll do it
no we don't have hr i wasn't we don't
have hr i wasn't wishing i'll tell i'll
tell ish
this is open harassment day
no
no i don't i don't think it
what the way the night the analogy put
it in it makes sense because you're able
on harassment day you're able just to
ask him okay no bet all right back up
that's fine
how would how would harassment day go
here i i don't know i don't i feel like
it should just be like okay
i feel like i feel like it wouldn't do
anything or try anything hold on let's
call him but i feel like he would
express okay
let's call them let's call them
hey quick i just want to let you know
something real quick
tomorrow's harassment day
yeah yeah so like all harassment is open
for business tomorrow
um sorry i'm not taking a holiday
what what the [ __ ] no holiday
no no harassment day not holiday
harassment so so any any harassing we
want to do all year you can't do all
your only tomorrow
no no
he's like i don't want no partisan what
the you're about to get
what for a second i thought
just no okay just you know any question
you want to do tomorrow
okay okay just
it's like
it's like did i stutter
nah he know he knows what you're talking
about anyway so we just we i thought
we'd bring back workplace harassment so
tomorrow
i like it um
[Laughter]
no i'm saying like anyone like like
tomorrow's like workplace harassment day
all right well i don't know
do what that what you want and i don't
know like what did you what did you have
in mind um
well i'm just letting you know if you
want to if you want to if you want if
you're you're you're a man you're a
fisherman right if you want to
ask anyone you can
ask people tomorrow
[Laughter]
yeah i'm just letting you know i'm
giving you the sexual harassment card
um
what causes you guys
we also wait no women always have the
sex ass makeup what card do we get
nothing i think we're just giving it's
like this is a men's rights channel so
we're yeah all right
just you know
i should i let sarah know too
yeah
okay okay i'll call him i'll call him
i'll call him okay okay i'll see i'll
talk to you later
bye should i should i call sarah
hey sarah what's going on i just wanna
i'm i'm doing a company announcement you
did what a company announcement oh wow
okay yeah so tomorrow it's sex
harassment day i'm just letting you know
no no no not live just like as as a
business like we're doing sex harassment
day
no no since women always have the sexual
harassment card like we can always do it
we're giving it to the men i'm just
letting you know
[Laughter]
oh okay okay i'm just i'm just letting
you know like
yeah this is it's
harassment day so
yeah that's what we're reacting to now
yeah we just watched the video we were
inspired so yeah we're just letting all
the all the all the men know you have a
sexual harassment card what
jack jess yeah jess hi sarah
don't bite your lip like that
no not till tomorrow it's not midnight
it's not this night what is he gas on
the
it's like did i stutter did i stutter
when i said tomorrow
i don't want no police
on the podcast tomorrow
i'll let him know i'll let him
know oh goodness as soon as i step
through the door
swear game
yeah fair game
okay i'll talk to you later just wanted
to let you know
yeah so you could say it's going well
it's just like it's just like
it's just i told you
ish ish would be hesitant you probably
wouldn't do something sorry doesn't care
in the name of you you can't say we
don't we don't care about men's rights
on this channel that's right yeah men's
rights oh this is going to be
well if you want to see how it plays out
vlog um sign up for the ten dollar tier
yes it will be a vlog all day tomorrow i
hope you guys enjoyed that video is very
entertaining it was our first time
watching
um
patrice o'neil i know he's he's great i
wanna i can't wait to watch more of him
um
also before you
leave make sure you like comment and
subscribe but comment down what other
videos
we should react to and also sign up for
memberships if you want to see
vlogs yeah sexual harmony um but without
that have a great
night